i was in this group called the young
writers i was i was in a group also
called the young writers with peace oh
my
god wow it was an audition unlike
anything we've ever seen before on last
night's season 20 premiere of the voice
and i think it's safe to say we were all
pretty shocked when blake shelton's old
band mate pete morose
auditioned and the coach didn't even
recognize him
the singer wowed the judges with his
performance of can't find my way home
but blake
didn't even realize their history until
he revealed his name was once pete
mitchell and that he played in a band
called the young riders tell us a little
bit about yourself
i think i'm the old guy here i don't
think so he's the only blake
impossible yeah i'm gonna get to you
okay sounds like there's some history
there and that's normally not a good
thing with me
he pointed to you when you turned around
no i cut my chops writing songs in
nashville and
i sang under a name pete mitchell i know
oh
was in this group called the young
writers i was
i was in a group also called the young
writers with peace oh my god
wow are you
are you serious i've seen in 25
years 25 years 25 years
[Applause]
you stole my bass player
no i got you oh my god i got your bass
player a job
i love this story so much i mean i guess
a lot can change in 25 years right
let's be honest even blake is
practically unrecognizable without those
luscious locks he had at the beginning
of his career
now the coaches tried to convince p to
go with john but ultimately
he went with the old cowboy and the band
is officially back together
how perfect is it that john legend
turned his chair for you
i love this idea you got to go with john
and i'm not against blake he's a buddy
that's funny because it sounds like
you're going against blake right there
i am totally going against blake
obviously
we would have a blast if we got to work
together again
no joke i would love it pete who do you
pick as your coach
[Music]
[Applause]
i gotta go with the old cowboys
were all literally little kids back then
like totally
i used to be skinny hey man
as soon as we can hug you're getting a
big hug and a kiss bro